[Music]
a wet weekend in bury greater manchester
but the town will soon be brightened up
by 40 million pounds from the
government's leveling up fund
this week boris johnson embarks on a
leveling up tour of the uk that will
include north west england
here in bury north where the
conservatives have a majority over labor
of just over a hundred voters are not
surprisingly split in their verdict on
the prime minister and levelling up
i think they should just let him get on
with it he's going to get himself out of
a bit of a ditch but i just think he's
in a lot of trouble and there's no way
out for him the south will always be the
south the north will always be the north
the south will always get the thicker
under the wedge it's always been that
way and it'll never change i think it's
it's it's done
it's good
the pm's tour visiting parts of the uk
earmarked for investment starts in
scotland with a visit to a manufacturing
site and research and development
projects
but his trip north of the border comes
just weeks after the tory's leader in
scotland douglas ross called for him to
quit over the partygate scandal
and they're not expected to meet
cabinet allies insist however that the
pm is not distracted by the police
inquiry into alleged parties in downing
street he will actually be very very
focused on the issues that matter to all
of us we've got a prime minister who is
now bringing the world together in terms
of how we do with russia and ukraine
he's working within this country about
dealing with this covered
after problem we've got the crisis we're
seeing in the health service dealing
with the backlog of that dealing with
the issues that people care about our
energy costs they're what he's focused
on and that's absolutely right where he
should be focused okay because that's
what makes our country better
the prime minister says he's getting out
of london this week and taking a simple
message with him that his government is
getting on with the job of uniting and
levelling up the country
continuing his drive to cut hospital
waiting times in northwest england mr
johnson will visit a cancer treatment
center to see how the nhs is tackling
covid backlogs
but health bosses claim staff shortages
are the big problem and the nhs needs to
recruit more nurses and doctors i'm
incredibly frustrated about the fact
that the government will not sign up to
the idea of a proper long-term workforce
plan which is what we have in every
other sector of our economy and what we
have in every other national health
system i can't understand why the
government won't sign up to what seems
to me to be blindingly obvious
and while the pm may be happy to escape
westminster the questions about the
downing street parties have not gone
away john craig sky news